josh fight benson
yeah yeah did he punch you in the thigh
no well you found him in uh you punched
me in the dick you found him in bellator
he punched you in the dick i fought him
in the ufc he punched you in the dick
yeah he's joshua truck huh
yeah
you know what he's right i haven't drank
any he's got to do it hey josh i'm
slowed down
this is [ __ ] he took a flight from
ireland drink more whiskey because i
wanna have to because you guys are so
funny i want you to read the [ __ ]
man's gamepads
josh you're reading the mansion greatest
[ __ ] ever keep drinking bro i'll pay for
your uber and you're reading that you
read the message i do [ __ ] drunk
[ __ ] i just realized
wait wait i know
i think he forgets i flew from ireland i
know morning yeah but why do you sound
irish
i [ __ ] have got like i've got like
four hours like 76 hours i love you
you're safe here but you try i'm
it's a perfect store for josh it's like
perfect
i'm gonna kick you in the [ __ ] right
now i swear to god there you go no
you're not wrong
[ __ ] this is a great shut up back to
this come over here
get him more whiskey right now i want
him to read that landscape ted
josh you're reading that manscaping you
know you're not leaving this room right
now